now a look at the ways to improve our
money habits after a challenging
economic year
a recent study found nearly four in 10
americans believe they'll be in
financial survival mode
in 2021 cbs news business analyst jill
schlesinger joins us with some financial
tips for the new year
jill happy new year good morning as i
said so many people are struggling right
now
what can they do what should they do to
try to regain some
financial control
well happy new year to you and i think
the core concept we always stress
is number one track where your money is
going
you've got to account for what's coming
in what's going out
and that will allow you to prioritize
your goals and objectives
now technology makes it a lot easier
there's some great apps big banks
all have apps that help you do this
there's also
clarity money there's mint but this is
important whether you have a job
whether you're unemployed you've got to
understand
where your condition lies and only by
tracking your money
will that allow you will you be able to
do that jill
one in three americans adults according
to a pew survey has dipped into their
savings or retirement accounts
how do we begin to rebuild that
well once you've got that tracking of
your expenses down now you can kind of
figure out what your priorities should
be and i think we all learned this
lesson throughout the pandemic
it is vitally important to have an
emergency reserve fund
this is the first concept that i call of
my big three
and you know eight in ten americans
right now are focusing on rebuilding
those emergency reserve funds you wanna
strive for
six to twelve months of your living
expenses
the next aspect of the big three number
two
pay down that high interest debt like
credit card debt
do your best to get a jump on that and
the third part
is to fund your retirement plan to the
best of your ability
now look use technology to help you with
all of this you can automatically
transfer funds so easily
you can set up automatic payments to get
rid of that debt
and you certainly can up the percentages
that you put into your retirement
accounts
these are your three cornerstones of how
you can achieve
some financial success in 2021 it's
still
a very uncertain time jill markets
remain volatile if you do have money to
invest
what should you be doing with it
boy 2020 what a year of learning for
every investor
and what we really take away from that
or what i take away with that is
you don't know when the market's going
up or down back in the spring
if you thought the world was coming to
an end you might have sold everything
but then it's really hard to get back in
so you've got to make sure you
don't try to time the market you want to
stick to your game plan
if you don't have a game plan now's a
good time to start one right
and you've got to make sure that your
emotions don't creep in
if you're going to make a change pinky
swear with yourself you're not going to
be swayed when the market moves one way
or the other
so those are your tips going forward
it's every investor's guideline right
anthony
thanks jill schlesinger happy new year
again jill